I'll be back I try to never say it in my
life it's like I'll be back I'm so
excited by this angela bassett is
joining me now I can hardly breathe I
love you so much
are you excited to see Linda back and in
Terminator were you a fan absolutely
she's such a tough lady and she and I
had biceps in common you did you're the
original icon abilities well Michelle
Turner was invited to hang out
exclusively on set of Terminator with
the terminator tough lady's approach my
work that way like yeah I'm 62 I'm
kicking ass after 28 years Linda's
returning to the Terminator franchise
that made her a star and would influence
the rest of her career for better and
for worse after t2 and when Hollywood
has a way of just sort of
compartmentalizing their actors and I
was just offered military women lesbians
and police officers so I was reluctant
to come back dark fate picks up where
Terminator 2 left off meaning rise of
the machines salvation and Genesis never
happened 1997 was supposed to be
Judgment Day the movie also introduces
two tough ladies by Linda side they are
my dream team Natalia Reyes and
Mackenzie Davis couldn't wait to learn
from Linda we're very excited to be her
sidekicks I feel exhausted she still
does like yeah one more like how can I
say I'm tired she not the stunts and
muscles are real but Linda's hair I dyed
it gray like I don't have gray hair yet
but I just wanted to distinguish myself
from the
zircon hurt but some things never change
I can see you're very upset when you
step back on the set with Arnold for the
first time you know what it was really
lovely truly I just want to hug him all
the time and this is all over I am going
to kill you I understand
[Music]